votre majesté il me revient après ces
longues années de guerre etc estrade de
veiller à tout prix à maintenir la paix
nous pensons pour cela que votre mariage
avec votre cousine germaine la fille de
philippe 5 euros d'esprit
donnerait à la relation entre nos deux
pays un ton apaisé
ma chère fille vous voilà désormais
reine de france
quant à vous mon fils nous allons vous
marier à louise elisabeth d'orléans
je ne veux pas les messieurs pourrait
gérer ses intrigues et pour y parvenir
les princesses ou faites pour être
marqués et perpétuer une dynastie
[Musique]
et
je suis charmé que vous ayez fait bon
voyage
je ne mangeais pas madame ou et manger
avec les toits si vous le souhaitez un
je me souviens que l'on ne possédait pas
autrement à versailles
oui
c'est l'avenir de l'europe qui se joue
ici le roi d'espagne peut être
imprévisible que dit exactement vos
excuses votre fille s'acclimate
difficilement comice man contraire
aurait étonné non
j'aurais dit le roi pathétique là je
crois qu'il est urgent d'assurer votre
descendance
je crains que la vente soit inadapté
pour un tel emploi vient mais vous le
prochain à cet enfant il vomit ministre
[Musique]
mon